alright so for all you adults out there
who got over the part of your life you
know being afraid of the dark it's okay
Hollywood's bringing it back for it
lights out
so lights out is a scary movie a horror
movie about this entity that haunts
these people is terrorizing this family
cool little take it can't survive in the
light if you turn the lights on you're
fine turn the lights out this creepy
silhouette with glowing eyes is there
it's gonna terrorize you it's really
cool so you could be running after you
just turn on the light with things gone
yes stay out of the shadows now which I
love that premise because we all have in
it I mean this come this comes from back
in the caves we're wired to be afraid of
the dark because at a time when we would
go out in the night and then we weren't
the biggest predators on the block that
fear kept us alive we still have that in
our heads so now horror movies just to
bring that out of us and this does it in
a really cool way that preys on that
very premise stay out of the dark and
not only is that a cool take on the
haunting genre but it's not it's
different than just a haunting movie the
trailers show way too much of the plot
so if you can stay away from the trailer
before you watch this movie do that
it'll do some good but I love me a fresh
new take in the horror genre also the
performances were good there's a little
kid in the movie and you're like little
oh the kid actually does really well so
does the girl in this movie so does
Maria bellows the mom in this movie you
can tell she's like not okay again
adding layers to a horror movie that
usually horror movies just pass up in
like hey jump scares what else you want
and there were some genuine scenes have
not jump-scare but like tension you see
that hand creep around the corner just
it wraps around the doorframe like that
you're like oh [ __ ] turn on like I mean
the last act of this movie alone had
everything you want from a movie like
this tension it was suspenseful it was
scary it was eerie
granted it does have its horror movie
cliches where you're like you guys are
doing stupid that don't do stupid things
like the sisters like hey little brother
do you want me to leave the door open or
close we're gonna crash downstairs we
know this thing is in this house y'all
right you want to sleep in your room
suite door open or closed kids like
clothes I'm like you're all dumb right
now group together and leave the door
open with all the what are you doing and
I guess this movie started out as a
short film online and now it's a feature
film didn't know where to shoehorn this
information in there so I just there's
no segue whatsoever I'm just letting you
know that I think that's pretty cool
more along the lines of not every short
film makes a good feature-length film
sometimes you're like oh you should have
left it as a short enough this did a
great job I could go for some more
explanation as to how this is all
happiness really starts to tell you how
it's happening and in the end something
happens in the movie that just assumes
that you know everything you need to
know and you don't really you narrow it
down to a point you can make a leap you
can go okay I think this is how this
happened but in the end it is a think
thing I mean there are like three
different possibilities as to how this
movie is happening as a whole one is
more likely than the other two but still
the other two are not negated it's not
in a oh well you know it's kind of open
that's intriguing
get to think about it kind of way no
it's actually getting in a way where you
feel like there should have been more
information for you that just wasn't
there guys in the end lights out was
suspenseful it was creepy it was anxiety
it was scary in parts and your
performances gave me what I wanted and
more in this movie because I you can
only expect so much in horror movies
these days this does deliver a bit more
and I will say lights out is worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray
alright guys so lights out have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more